all right so here's what I have been
building to
with this Trump getting booed for
suggesting people get vaccinated at his
Alabama rally for months now really
since the 2020 election we've been
talking about how can we deprogram these
trumpists how can we bring tens of
millions of people back to having some
semblance of a connection with reality
and so that they can be meaningful
participants in American society rather
than just people getting in the way that
we have to sort of get around in order
to get anything done and we haven't been
able to figure it out and normally in
history when you look at when there have
been massive shifts in public
Consciousness when you look at massive
cultural shifts massive when when things
happen that quickly usually it's because
some dictator has come in and imposed an
authoritarian dictatorial government one
of the greatest examples of this is the
Chinese Cultural Revolution where you
had it wasn't that people's views just
evolved naturally really quickly it was
that you had a a dictatorial
authoritarian government come in and say
this is the new culture
that is not likely to happen in the
United States so and that's good and so
absent that the question we've been
asking is how do we bring these people
back and I really thought a lot about
this during my trip to Europe from which
I came back last week because I was just
in a place without trumpists for a
little bit and it sort of gave me some
context and my feeling is increasingly
these people are too far gone they can't
be brought back now I'm not throwing in
the towel I still think we continue to
talk about it and figure this out but I
do believe that for the most part these
people are too far gone and then the
cherry on top I think was at the rally
Saturday night in Alabama where Trump
says to his own sycophants I mean
there's no greater suck-ups for Trump
than the people that spend 12 hours
waiting for him at a rally Trump says
the vaccine is good go and get it and
then they jeer and they boo I mean this
is the Trump that could shoot people on
Fifth Avenue and not lose his supporters
and he says the vaccine is good go and
get it and they boo who and he
immediately has to backtrack I played
this clip in the segment about the rally
but let's just look at it one more time
three days less than nine months and
it's great and you know what I believe
totally in your freedoms I do free you
got to do what you have to do but
I recommend taking the vaccines I did it
it's good take the vaccines but you got
now that's okay that's all right you got
your freedoms
but I happen to take the vaccine if it
doesn't work you'll be the first to know
okay
I'll call up Alabama and say hey you
know what
but it is working but uh you do have
your freedoms you have to keep you have
to maintain that you have to maintain
that and you got to get your kids back
to school
that's sort of like game set match for
me guys I mean I'm I'm ready to declare
it these people are too far gone to be
brought back at the mass scale level now
at some micro level we regularly hear
you know I've been working on my crazy
cousin for for four months and now
they've changed their mind that can
happen but at a mass scale I don't know
that we're bringing these people back
and so Trump has really lost control of
his own monster if he can't control it
nobody can I use the analogy earlier of
you get a protection dog and it's so
aggressive it's dangerous even to the
owner it's trying to protect you lose
control of the dog uh Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein isn't a you know that these
are these are the thoughts that I'm
having and as I asked earlier I think
this is the correct me if I'm wrong I
think this is the first time a rally
crowd has actually booed something that
Donald Trump said and Trump really
needed to be promoting the vaccine in a
more real way before he left office
between January 16 in January 20th not
as I'm great because I got us the
vaccine and Biden will screw it up but
just everybody get it it's safe it's
effective it wasn't really available
while Donald Trump was still in office
but it's just too late for that the
damage was done and it shouldn't really
surprise us that now his own crowd booze
him when he says get vaccinated because
Trump refused to wear a mask in 2020
he called it the China virus and a hoax
and Trump continued to do all of the
things that would encourage people
ultimately not to get vaccinated and I
don't think we can get him back at this
point in time so sanity in the American
right wing returning if we ever had it
is going to depend on young people who
aren't yet political now hopefully we
can pull those people left but if they
end up on the right maybe they would be
not crazy like these trumpists non-trump
Republicans who maybe can grow their
share of the party but I don't know that
these tens of millions of people can be
brought back Trump broke them and even
he can't fix them and that's really
crazy
um the vaccine now exists in this other
America almost like this Mark of the
Beast that they talk about and some
wrote to me saying David don't worry
about it it's darwinian but it's it's
really not first of all because many of
those people already had kids and some
of them even brought their kids to this
rally darwinian would be some trait
that's disadvantageous to reproduction
but a lot of these people have already
reproduced and then as far as the
vaccines go as I mentioned earlier
I suspect one of the most effective ways
to get these people to get vaccinated
would be you say health care companies
say if you are unvaccinated and you need
covid treatment you don't pay a co-pay
you straight up pay 50 of what it costs
and that can be tens of thousands or
even hundreds of thousands of dollars I
think that gets a bunch of these people
to become vaccinated but in some sense
a lot of this makes perfect sense that
this is the way they would feel at this
point because for the last 18 months
they were told Cove it's not real
or it's real but it's not serious
we don't need to change anything about
our day-to-day the vaccines may not work
the vaccine is experimental Joe Biden
will force vaccinations the vaccine
might kill you it might magnetize you
all this different stuff and now you
know in late August of 2021 Trump says
the vaccine is good go and get it in
some sense of course they booed what
happens next I have no idea if you think
these people are not too far gone I want
to hear from you and tell me exactly how
we bring them back to reality we'll have
more on this on our Instagram which you
can find at davidpackman show